bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7 8 sur
tv fil 78 en direct à partir de 18
heures une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale et comme chaque lundi
le point complet sur l'actualité
sportive c'est avec anthony rech pont
soir anthony bonsoir nous voir dans une
vingtaine de minutes ce soir oui tout à
fait nous commençons tout d'abord avec
le vendée globe nous aurions nous
devrions être en direct avec le skipper
versailles et tanguy de lamotte qui est
au large du cap de bonne espérance nous
ferons aussi un petit retour en arrière
en 1982 précisément avec karl olive
hauteur des carnets secrets de michel
hidalgo un livre trésor qui relate les
causeries du sélectionneur français lors
de la coupe du monde espagnol et enfin
nous ferons un point à la mi saison avec
le coach de l'équipe première du père
c'est le plaisir rugby club qui vient de
terminer sa phase aller troisième du
championnat de fédérale 3 et puis comme
d'habitude en fin de chronique tous les
résultats du week-end tous les résultats
à découvrir au cours de cette nouvelle
édition du 7 suite voilà pour les
grandes lignes du programme sportif
l'art est le reste du somerset en images
à présent à l'inauguration de la faculté
des sciences de la santé à saint quentin
en yvelines en présence à de la ministre
marisol touraine que vous allez entendre
dans un instant en plateau avec des
invités nous parlerons des enjeux pour
le territoire notamment afin de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux
elle la journée de lutte contre le sida
le 1er décembre avec cette mobilisation
des jeunes de montigny le bretonneux
afin de récolter des fonds pour
l'association hf prévention en sport
première édition du trail nocturne de
versailles et c'est un succès samedi
soir ils étaient 200 à s'élancer sur un
parcours de 18 km préparé par les élèves
du lycée marie-curie de versailles et
puis le département des yvelines regorge
de champion le conseil général a
souhaité récompenser ceux qui se sont
illustrés en 2012 notamment lors des
jeux de londres l'information du jour
c'est donc l'inauguration de cette
faculté des sciences de la santé
inauguration officielle cet après midi à
saint quentin en yvelines et ce chiffre
le chiffre de cette édition 13400 c'est
la superficie en mètres carrés du site
pour continuer d'ailleurs avec les
chiffres cinq mille 700 m² dédiés à la
recherche médicale 1200 étudiants
également budget total pour la
construction
52,8 millions d'euros de tous ces
chiffres et de beaucoup d'autres sujets
nous allons parler donc avec nos invités
et j'accueille donc robert cadalbert
bonsoir président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à vos côté
christine etchemendy garées selon lui
presque réussi à pas écorcher votre nom
bonsoir à vous vous êtes directrice du
département maïeutique dont sept
nouvelles facultés donc c'est les sages
femmes voilà pour faire au plus simple
et puis ils fassent avoue robert
cadalbert nous avons un étudiant
également florien mon cas bonsoir
étudiant en 3e année de formation
générale en sciences médicales donc là
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines déjà un mot
robert cadalbert on a le sentiment avec
la journée qui s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui et puis avec la tente aussi
suscité par ce site qu'il ya un
véritable enjeu aujourd'hui qui se joue
avec l'arrivée de cette faculté des
sciences de la santé pourquoi c'est si
important pour un territoire ont écouté
le développement de l'université si on
croit son avenir c'est d'abord le
l'avenir de son de ces jeunes et
l'avenir de son université et
qu'aujourd'hui avec l'inauguration de
l'ufr des sciences de la santé ça a été
un point d'orgue de 20 ans de travail
avec tout le monde avec les financeurs
d'abord pour qu'effectivement on voit le
jour ce nouveau bâtiment qui va
permettre aux étudiants de saint quentin
en yvelines mais deux largement des
yvelines de pouvoir se former pas
simplement dans la médecine c'est bien
pour ça que le terme ufr des sciences de
la santé importants mais aussi bien
infirmières maïeutique qui n'est d'avoir
effectivement tous les profils de santé
formés sur le territoire il y avait du
monde lors de cette inauguration vous
avez aperçu sur les quelques images
simone veil notamment à la ministre
l'ancienne ministre de la santé qui
était présente nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure et puis également marisol
touraine c'est la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé elle nous
l'avons rencontré à la l'issue de cette
inauguration au micro de catherine
dilatoire c'est une idée qui doit faire
école parce que aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus opposer la médecine d'un côté aux
autres professionnels de santé ce qui
vient trop souvent à l'esprit
nous savons que l'avenir de notre
système de santé réside dans la
coopération entre les médecins et parmi
les médecins entre les médecins
généralistes les médecins qui
travaillent sur telle ou telle
pathologie sur les médecins de ville et
les médecins hospitaliers mais sur aussi
de la coopération avec les infirmières
les kinés les orthophonistes des
pharmaciens et donc c'est un ensemble
que nous devons promouvoir c'est un
grand défi parce que la france en
général et la médecine en particulier a
eu tendance à fonctionner de manière
cloisonnée dont je me réjouis que dans
un lieu de formation
dans un lieu d'enseignement et bien on
forme les plus jeunes ceux qui seront
les professionnels de demain d'emblée à
un esprit de coopération de
rapprochement et de solidarité dans le
travail m à l'autre défi ce sont les la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux ici on
a parlé de maisons de santé
universitaire c'est pour ça que c'est
ufr est implanté en vivent c'est laid il
faut pouvoir former à proximité de
tétouan où il nous faudra appeler
espérer l'implantation de médecins vous
savez si tous les étudiants sont formés
en centre ville si tous les étudiants
passent l'ensemble de leur cursus
universitaire à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
il y a peu de chances pour qu'ils aient
envie d'aller s'installer à l'extérieur
de l'hôpital et encore moins à
l'extérieur des grandes villes donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu tout à fait
important rapprocher la formation des
lieux d'installation à venir et c'est la
raison aussi pour laquelle j'insiste
beaucoup j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
à plusieurs reprises j'insiste beaucoup
sur la nécessité de développer des
stages contre les déserts médicaux vous
allez présenter quelque chose je crois
le 13 décembre voilà j'en aurai
l'occasion d'annoncer un ensemble de
mesures vous savez il n'ya pas une
mesure miracle le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale a
d'ores et déjà prévu le financement pour
des mesures importantes comme celle de
la sécurisation de l'installation des
jeunes médecins pendant deux ans c'est
ce que nous allons appeler les
praticiens territoriaux de médecine
générale et c'est eux qui seront
soutenus financièrement pendant l'app le
tout début de leur installation mais
évidemment ça n'est qu'une mesure parmi
d'autres et c'est un plan global
cohérent appuyé sur une volonté
politique très fort car je crois que la
volonté est indispensable qui permettra
de mieux lutter contre les déserts
médicaux la ministre a pris concernant
la colère des médecins qu'est ce que
vous avez envie de leur répondre il
manifestait encore aujourd'hui ils
estiment qu'ils ne sont pas les seuls
responsables des dépassements
d'honoraires il ya eu un accord signé
par une majorité de syndicats
représentatifs sur les dépassements
d'honoraires une grande majorité de
médecins considèrent qu'il faut pouvoir
à la fois éviter les abus et garantir
l'accès aux soins de nos concitoyens je
veux le dire cet accord est un accord
juste équilibré et qui permet surtout à
nos concitoyens d'avoir de plus grandes
garanties dans l'accès aux soins
marisol touraine donc qui répondait aux
questions de catherine zola tôt c'était
enfin à d'après-midi les 18 heures
passées de quelques minutes si vous nous
suivez en direct on parle donc de
l'inauguration de cette faculté des
sciences de la santé il ya eu plusieurs
choses dans cette intervention de la
ministre qu'on a pu entendre et
principalement cette intervention autour
des déserts médicaux c'est à dire qu'il
faut éviter ces zones où les médecins ne
s'installent plus où les médecins ne
vont plus et j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question puisque vous êtes
enseignante et directrice donc du tap du
département de maillots tic est ce que
les étudiants qui font leurs études sur
un site il reste ensuite
alors certains étudiants restent sur les
sites où ils ont réalisé des stages
souvent assez vite l'implantation
facilitons malgré tout flamme en
l'occurrence tout elle sur les
territoires cela facilite tout à fait à
l'implantation des professionnels je ne
m'en diplômés sur le territoire ont posé
la question à l'étudiant aussi vous avez
l'intention de rester ici à l'issue de
vos études pour ma part pourquoi pas
c'est vrai que quand on étudie dans une
région on est forcément attaché est bon
c'est vrai que les études de médecine
sont assez longues ont fait 6 ans
jusqu'aux concours de l'internât pour
pouvoir savoir dans quelle région on va
ensuite allés se former et si la
possibilité si j'ai la possibilité de
rester ici pour ma part je resterai en
région parisienne après je peux
comprendre que ce ne soit pas le point
de vue tous les étudiants et que
certains aient besoin aussi de partir de
deux endroits ce sera pour exercer dans
quelle profession spécifiquement aux
pour l'instant je ne sais pas encore
quoi sans certitude général exactement
troisième année je le disais tout à
l'heure robert cadalbert saas est un
enjeu important pour un territoire le
département des yvelines saint quentin
en yvelines n'est pas épargné par cette
pénurie de médecins à long terme
plusieurs études l'ont prouvé même sur
saint quentin en yvelines certaines
zones manquons de docteur oui surtout
que la ville nouvelle s'est construit
essentiellement il ya 30 ans avec
l'arrivée de nombreux nombreuses
professions de santé et 30 ans après ben
il a la plupart doivent prendre leur
retraite et une retraite bien méritée et
comme ils ont une éthique très forte qui
se posent des questions que faire après
s'ils n'ont pas des remplaçants c'est
vrai un vrai problème et c'est pour ça
que l'arrivée de cette université et ces
deux facultés des sciences de la santé
pour nous très importante parce qu'elle
va de même il ya un an par exemple
jouent au jeu ont signé le premier
contrat local de santé alors c'est pas
simplement un acte administratif c'est
pour nous important avec la sude
promotion de la santé qui a fédéré tous
les partenaires de la santé de saint
quentin en yvelines et particulièrement
les réseaux de santé de professionnels
de leuc ahmad le pallium mais aussi sa
permis de lancer des opérations soit
avec les hôpitaux on a un centre
d'addictologie avec l'hôpital mignot on
a un centre de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit aussi à l'hôpital mignot sans
compter que un des succès de sûreté at
war c'est ce qu'a fait l'association des
médecins des trois villages avec une
garde une garde médicale pour donner un
exemple il ya quatre mille personnes qui
passent à cette garde il va fêter ses
dix ans de l'accession deuxième les oui
voilà comment sont les trois pour pour
l'ensemble de 50 ans l'insee
le basée à st à montigny mais couvre
l'ensemble des agglomérations et là au
delà de saint quentin évident car et
4000 personnes qui vont la maison de
garde 40 qui vont aux urgences à mignot
vous voyez l'économie savez ce que c'est
qu'un passage aux urgences de ne pas que
c'est pas agréable pour les gens et en
plus ça fait des économies voilà un bel
exemple où on peut faire mieux avec ce
en plus d'argent mais faire mieux voilà
développer les différentes synergies par
exemple cette faculté des sciences de la
santé va s'ouvrir sur l'extérieur elle
va travailler avec lee ps aussi
peut-être lampiris innovation de la
santé des magiciens et le départ de la
glace elle le fait déjà
l'ensemble de dessous des partenaires de
la santé sont partie prenante on a même
créé avec l'ufr des sciences de la santé
une unité mixte territoire et faculté
des sciences de la santé ce qui permet
de non seulement d'organiser des
manifestations comme celle d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi de préparer ce qui nous tient
le plus à coeur c'est l'organisation des
soins de premier recours dans les
quartiers donc là on touche tout à fait
les problèmes d'implantation des
professions de santé on pense à des
maisons universitaire de santé
territorialisée qui vont permettre à la
fois aux praticiens de s'organiser
collectivement une pratique collective
de la médecine et de la santé et en même
temps d'assumer dès la formation pour
accueillir les jeunes médecins d'assumer
la prévention par exemple avec la la
cpam caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
pour assurer par exemple le projet santé
active et aussi pour un autre exemple
l'éducation thérapeutique que l'hôpital
mais au fait au lieu de la faire le
piano mignot vaut mieux la faire
directement dans les quartiers dans les
maisons de santé voilà un bel exemple de
coopération au service des habitants au
service de l'intérêt général à chaque
fois tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
est dit par robert cadalbert vous
partager pleinement cet avis ces
échanges qui vont avoir lieu par exemple
concrètement sur sur votre service une
maïeutique vous allez pouvoir échanger
avoir des échanges plus large
aujourd'hui maintenant que s'est
installée là du côté de 50 ans nul et
oui hélas plusieurs niveaux d'une pincée
tout d'abord participé justement ce type
de projet de maison de santé
universitaire et territoriales d'une
part et d'autre part se retrouver
auprès des différents départements
d'enseignement tels que le département
de médecine générale ou des staps nous
permet d'envisager des projets vraiment
de collaboration étroite est également
aussi au niveau des laboratoires de
recherche puisque d'une part
l'enseignement se base sur le travail et
les travaux de recherche et et d'avoir
sur une unité de lieu à la fois
l'enseignement et puis à la fois
également laboratoire de recherche nous
permet d'envisager une collaboration
étroite je pense en particulier pour la
maïeutique au laboratoire du professeur
arnaud fauconnier de périnatalité de
gestion des risques en périnatalité
voilà mais également le laboratoire de
santé publique pour la prévention auprès
des femmes et des couples 1 donc c'est
essentiel pour le développement de cette
unité en charge des futures sages-femmes
et qui est qu'ils exerceront ensuite
dans les prochaines années en tant
qu'étudiant aussi vous avec les
différents échanges qu'il peut y avoir
entre ses différentes institutions
parler du ps on aurait pu mentionner
gérer handicap aussi tout à l'heure
c'est important ça facilite aussi les
stages concrètement même pour intervenir
pour vous mais c'est vrai que pour nous
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'avoir une
réelle faculté qui centralise toutes ces
problématiques là et le coup les stages
que ce soit des stages par exemple si on
veut faire des stages de recherche on
peut très bien maintenant les faire dans
notre faculté et ça facilite vraiment
une réelle cohésion au sein de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines et ça
permet vraiment de
tourner deux d'être soudés derrière
cette faculté juste une parenthèse vous
avez commencé votre cycle d'études en
médecine dans les locaux temporaires qui
arrivera en france mais on court
toujours des clans de la faculté de
saint quentin ça va complètement là oui
oui oui j'ai commencé donc la première
année commune des études de santé dans
le bâtiment bout d'alembert puis après
j'ai fait ma deuxième année dans des
bâtiments préfabriqués boulevard
rabelais et j'ai fait ma troisième année
dans ce nouveau bâtiment donc c'est vrai
que le changement est plutôt radical
entre des antilles théâtre qui
accueillait à peine 100 étudiants dans
des bâtiments préfabriqués à la une
université qui peut accueillir 1200
étudiants à la fois les premières années
ainsi que les deuxième et troisième
années et ça permet aussi au niveau du
troisième cycle de médecine générale
ainsi que département de maïeutique qui
était sûr possible auparavant devenir
une faculté de la santé est ce utile à
un territoire et en quoi est ce utile à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est la
question que nous sommes allés poser
dans les rues de l'agglomération
aujourd'hui nécessaire oui de toute
façon une fac de médecine c'est bien
n'importe où mais pour saint quentin
c'est toujours important je suppose oui
c'est pas mal pour les jeunes je trouve
que ça leur évite d'aller plus loin ceux
qui vivent à saint quentin
montini voisins tous à la vallée de
chevreuse pas mal oui je pense que c'est
bien ça permet de ne pas aller très loin
faire ses études voilà maintenant elle à
saint quentin il ya un panel de fac
assez large oui ce que je comprends pas
bien c'est que les hôpitaux sont un peu
loin pour pour les étudiants mais bon
pour les premières années c'est pas très
gênant ça évite les déplacements sur
paris pourquoi pas oui je pense que
c'est un complète bien le pôle
universitaire
qui était déjà assez conséquent mais bon
c'est toujours un plus et nous parlons
donc ce soir de cette faculté des
sciences de la santé voilà pour quelques
réactions recueillies aujourd'hui dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
sur l'intérêt de l'implantation et vous
vouliez aussi nous préciser que vous
multipliez les échanges l'institut vous
n'aviez pas mentionné tout à l'heure
tout à fait avec les réseaux maternité
en yvelines et puis associé nous qui
couvre l'ensemble du département
d'accord alors de l'allant plantations
aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau site cette
nouvelle faculté ça change quoi
concrètement aussi pour pour vous au
quotidien vous étiez auparavant nous
étions situés sur le site de poissy dans
le centre hospitalier de poissy saint
germain en laye qui est notre hôpital de
rattachement et avec qui nous gardons
vraiment des liens renforcés puisque
c'est vraiment notre hôpital de
référence par rapport à tout
l'enseignement clinique en particulier
des stages là vous êtes plus loin de
l'hôpital oui mais les étudiants sont en
alternance donc avec des périodes de
cours d'enseignement théorique et des
périodes de stages d'enseignement
clinique ce qui ne pose aucun problème
l'avantagé c'est là où les étudiants
sont vraiment ravi d'une part de ces
échanges et ses collaborations
interfilières qui se renforcent qui
était déjà réelle puisque il démarrait
dès la première année commune aux études
en santé d'une part et puis se retrouver
vraiment dans une ville qu'on s'en est
au coeur même de la ville avec sur le
campus universitaire avec à la fois
l'accès à la bibliothèque universitaire
la gare à 5 minutes ce sont des côtés
pratiques en tout cas qu'ils apprécient
grandement et je dirais surtout aussi
les échanges et puis être vraiment dans
des locaux
vraiment
splendide si je peux me permettre
avec une technique dont 2 millions de
confirmation 52 millions millions à
l'admiration mais ça fait 52 8 millions
de l'admiration plus le terrain qui est
pas négligeable dans la sphère qui était
donnée donc à l'université pour réaliser
cette construction donc ça véritablement
c'est important cet échange entre
filières ces passerelles oui vraiment
cessé passerelles ces échanges
interfilières c'est au niveau étudiants
et même au niveau professionnel est
vraiment a souligné et puis nous avons
aussi accès à des ressources
pédagogiques vraiment de pointe donc
c'est vraiment plus ça veut dire changer
facilement avec les autres étudiants oui
effectivement nous les étudiants
sages-femmes sont complètement avec nous
dans les locaux on a certes un cours qui
sont qui sont communs voilà c'est
mutualisé avec eux et c'est vrai que ça
nous permet comme plus tard
en tant que médecins et on aura
travaillera pas mal avec les sages
femmes après tout dépendra la spécialité
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de ces
médecins qui vont travailler avec les
sages femmes c'est vraiment important
dès maintenant de créer un lien et de
comprendre aussi les problématiques
elles peuvent avoir et inversement est
l'une des problématiques nous pouvons
avoir c'est aussi la connaissance je
dirais des compétences de chacun et
c'est aussi tout cela dans l'objectif
d'une prise en charge la plus optimale
possible ont fêté des passions
voilà par la connaissance et la coller
bonne collaboration délai les bancs de
la sécurité j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
présence de simone veil ce matin
aujourd'hui tout au long de la journée
sur cette journée d'inauguration
elle était présente tout simplement
parce que la faculté porte son nom le
nom de simone veil l'ancien ministre de
la santé qui a porté la loi autorisant l
ivg celle qui a également survécu à la
shoah était donc présente aujourd'hui à
saint quentin en yvelines et nous avons
demandé à quelques étudiants ce qu'il
pensait de ce nom donné à
l'établissement cette faculté
elle a une histoire elle a été déportée
acheter battus pour le droit à
l'avortement et elle représente vraiment
le
l'amélioration pour moi de la condition
féminine en sachant que ben voilà elle a
tout un passif très lourd et
je connais pas non plus très bien mais
dieu que je connaisse c'est c'est
quelqu'un enfin voilà elles forcent
l'admiration de ses symboles de courage
de détermination
en
tant que fille ça me plaît que
l'intéressé pas le simone veil c'est la
personne personne politique qui a
légalisé l'avortement en france c'était
en 64 14 75 pensent
trouver ça bien oui oui pourquoi pas
c'est une personne courageuse je pense
sa première fois que je crois qu une fac
de médecine prend le monde une personne
vivante
moi personnellement c'est encore un
sujet qui fait un qui fait débat pour
moi ça aurait été du être docteur nom
d'une politique et pas trop grand chose
à faire avec une fac de médecine s'est
battu toute sa vie elle a réussi à faire
passer le projet de loi sur l'avortement
je trouve que c'est quand même une
grande avancée tous deux pour les droits
des femmes je suis très contente
j'aimerais votre réaction à chacun pour
conclure ce plateau consacré à cette
faculté des sciences de la santé ce nom
de simone veil sur ce bâtiment sur cette
faculté ça représente quoi pour vous
c'est un vrai symbole d'ailleurs le
conseil d'administration a voté
pratiquement aligner 18 voilà lui donc
même s'il ya eu quelqu'un pour provoquer
je prends le quai qui voulaient pourquoi
pas le docteur le jeune voilà bon mais
il suffit de voir qu'elle use héros voit
donc c'était rassurant tous les cas pas
ce qu'ils vont faire c'est un grand
symbole également puisque en particulier
pour la maïeutique je dirais même au
delà de la santé de la femme est
vraiment madame veil a vraiment vrai
pour la santé des femmes et pour ça
nous lui en sommes en tout cas très
reconnaissante merci d'être venu sur ce
piano merci également à vous florian
banque a donc étudiants cette université
cette faculté d'être venu sur le plateau
robert cadalbert vous reste encore
quelques instants avec moi quelques
questions économiques encore à vous
poser sur un autre sujet mais ça
concerne l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines ce sera juste après
ce reportage de valérie auribeau et
d'élodie moines elles reviennent sur la
journée de mobilisation la de lutte
contre le sida du 1er décembre avec
cette opération menée à montigny le
bretonneux
ballon et tire lire en main les élus du
conseil municipal des jeunes entamé ce
samedi une collecte de dons pour la
deuxième année consécutive dans le cadre
du sidaction les dons vont venir à
l'association achète prévention qui sont
pour les tests de dépistage rapide pour
les milieux défavorisés
parallèlement à cette collecte une
exposition se tient au pôle jeunesse
informations dépistage et traitement
mieux comprendre le sida pour mieux s'en
protéger alors qui a dit que les jeunes
ne prenait pas la prévention au sérieux
justement non pas le on en parle assez
et que les jeunes agissent beaucoup et
je pense que le problème il vient
beaucoup des adultes qui pensent que
justement le préservatif c'est plus
utile que le test de dépistage quand on
n'est pas atteint ou contourne pense ne
pas être à risque ils ne font pas et je
pense que vraiment la jeunesse on prend
vraiment conscience et qui font les
tests qui est c'est vrai ça devient
vraiment réflexe ce week end
586 euros ont été récoltés
autre mobilisation elle concerne le
téléthon dernière ligne droite pour les
bénévoles à quatre jours du lancement de
l'opération et à magny les hameaux les
organisateurs annoncent la venue de
delphine racines et médaillé de bronze à
londres tire à la fosse elle viendra le
7 décembre à partir de 19h à la
rencontre du public et bien évidemment
aider à la collecte de fonds le 8
décembre à 14 heures toujours à magny
les hameaux elle c'est la comédienne
virginie lemoine qui sera présente ces
mêmes à la marraine du téléthon à
manille cette année rendez vous au
gymnase chantal mauduit